I remember coming home one night after a
big fight run up to the kitchen I get
ice and I'm my hands swollen and then
just another day at work there was a
time in my life when I said if I don't
if I'm not a star by the time I'm 18 I'm
gonna have to get out of the business
I remember the studio exec looking at me
and his food almost coming out of his
mouth
and going Vinnie we're not even sure we
want to make this one how could you talk
about three movies he's an American
actor producer director and screenwriter
he's best known for his role as Dominic
in the Fast & Furious series he made his
stage debut at age seven in the dinosaur
d'Or play and has been acting ever since
he's Vin Diesel and here's my take on
his top ten rules success rule number
one is my personal favorite I make sure
to stick around all the way to the end
for a special bonus clips and as always
a VIN says something that really
resonates with you please leave in the
comments below and put quotes around it
to other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
hi as you know I was a bouncer for many
years I remember coming home one night
after a big fight run up to the kitchen
I get ice and I'm my hands swollen and
then just another day at work and I was
feeling like just bummed about the fact
that I was still doing this job after
all this time and I'm at that one moment
I was like why aren't people what's up
why do people have so much anger why do
I have to you know why is this my daily
life to suppress everybody's anger or
check everybody's anger that comes in to
the giant 3,000 person nightclub and my
father it was so simple but my father
said you know then I've traveled around
the world I've been to India I've been
to Russia I've been to China I've been
all I've been to South and all through
South America and I've realized
something I said what he said people by
and large are good people
sounded pretty simple and yet it meant
so much and if you look at my facebook
page if you look at the way that all
that positive energy I don't think
there's a page in the world in history
that harbours is much positive energy as
one would see on this Facebook page and
it's when you put out tail and it's
really that right and I say that because
I say that because if you believe that
in your heart and not everybody watching
this can say that or is ready to say
that or it's comfortable with themselves
enough to say that but if you really
believe in your heart that people by and
large are good people it affects the way
that you address the world as you see
post in and post out I address a world
that in my soul I feel is comprised of
good people my advice to people who want
to pursue their dream is to find any way
that they can to make product my
philosophy is that product is the most
important thing I started acting when I
was 7 years old
and I didn't get paid as an actor until
I did Saving Private Ryan and I was 30
at that time so there was many many
years of unemployment obviously what I
learned later was that I had to have
something I had to have product
regardless of how big or small it was
and the first thing that I did was
direct a short film called multi facial
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't group I can't you'll die
why are you doing this why
[Music]
so then voice of Groot and possibly my
favorite character in the film what were
the difficulties of kind of expressing
yourself with such limited vocabulary
clearly the challenge and clearly a
challenge that a thesbian would never
expect to be confronted with and yet
thank God
that I did have the opportunity and the
challenge to do it because he is such a
special character um yes when Kevin
Feige called me he said ah let me
preface this phone call by telling you
that the character we're about to
discuss is the strangest character
Marvel has ever attempted to put on the
big screen and then he said however
because Iron Giant is a family favorite
um we believe that you can bring life to
this even though most people will only
hear you say I am and it was really it
was a shocker and and something very
challenging something very interesting
there's really my son my three-year-old
son when I came home with the book of
conceptual art and showed him all the
characters in the galaxy he pointed to
the tree as a character that he thought
was daddy everyone loves the tree
everyone knows sometimes you see someone
having enormous success and it's just
something about them you say good for
him and I think not just me but when I
read about the response to you lots of
people are saying that they're cheering
for you to have the accomplishments you
have had I feel that I've always felt a
sense of support
and I and I think that my struggle to
achieving this goal in achieving this
dream is something that speaks volumes
I started out acting at seven years old
and I struggled for so long there was a
time in my life when I said if I don't
if I'm not a star by the time I'm 18 I'm
gonna have to get out of the business
it's of course I jumped to 21 and then
25 and then I'm looking in the mirror
just past my mid-20s and I haven't I
haven't received health benefits in Sag
and we all know that with a Screen
Actors Guild yeah you got to make seven
thousand dollars in order to be eligible
for health benefits so fact I didn't get
health benefits until I was thirty years
old that even while I was shooting say
Brian
I wasn't covered ah and I think that
that kind of rise to fame is something
that's empowering for people so when
they when they celebrate that story I
think that they're also celebrating a
you know a story that's about a guy who
was proactive and resourceful and did
paged it was a big struggle and
persevered and believed in himself I
think you have to I think I think the
only thing I had for so many years was
this confidence that I held on to very
tightly it wasn't a difference in
confidence in arrogance I mean are you
glad to you just knew that you were
getting the skills necessary to be good
when one moment came you'd be ready and
could deliver right I I needed to be
confident at the risk even of being
arrogant I needed to be confident
because I had
nothing else and if you go into a
situation where you're dedicating your
whole life to something literally your
whole life all of your decisions are
made with one common goal then I think
that you'd better believe in yourself
especially if you start to work ah to
save money to make foams I think you
could ask most people in the world and
they would tell you that I'm not
Hollywood and and no but I mean but in a
good way and it's not a bad question to
ask because it's not even so Hollywood
how do you stay grounded when you have
90 million people waiting for you to say
something so while I'm here right now
and this will go out to how many other
people at home I know the second I hear
boom my computer comes on there are 90
million people waiting to hear something
that's tricky how do you make sense of
that
what would Marlon Brando have done if he
could have would there been a sequel to
on the waterfront maybe if there were
some fan on Texas I said I can't wait to
see another on the waterfront so do you
feel the pressure constantly or family
giver I do feel pressure III family
keeps you grounded because we might uh
fost task is good not going to be unlike
that other guys toughest task and that
the toughest task is to be the best
parent you can be we all share that we
all to be the best person you can be
we're all growing as individuals we're
all growing into our better selves those
are the things that that I stay focused
on I don't and I don't even know if I'm
not grounded I live in a fantasy world
of scenes in my head and future when I
came here
and I was about to do fast and furious
for they didn't think I was grounded
when I said I could shoot three movies
at the same time they thought I was
insane and they were like security get
him off the lot they never imagined it I
remember the studio exec looking at me
and his food almost coming out of his
mouth and going Vinnie we're not even
sure we want to make this one how could
you talk about three movies who cares
what happens in four five and six and
and now the only thing they want to know
is what's going to happen after this how
surreal incredible it's incredible one
of the interesting things about the way
that I did it was or one of the
interesting things about being paid the
amount of money being paid now for film
is back in in 1996 I was working to make
movies yeah so whether I you know was
saving $3,000 putting a savings of three
thousand dollars together which at the
time was a feat or working a whole year
telemarketing to save $47,000 I was
taking that money and investing it in my
career and investing in something that I
believed how do you invest in your
career well at that stage at that stage
if people aren't offering you roles the
interesting thing about being an actor
it's different thing the other art
mediums if you're an actor you're
dependent upon a director a screenwriter
a producer a studio two funded studio to
market the film and even after I made
its trades I didn't have land I went to
dramatic competition at Sundance I
didn't have a distributor so I could
only make the film and thank God there
was a forum thank God
Robert Redford had put together a forum
for these films to be shown and even
then even after you make the film and
you put the film in the can you still
have to have somebody to come along and
say I need to distribute the film so as
an actor you need all these external
factors to to be artistic if you're a
musician you could you know would shed
and make music if you're a painter yeah
you can do it alone you could do it
alone and the at being inactive is a lot
less autonomous so I needed to find a
way to fulfill all those other positions
I had to learn how to write screenplays
yeah so I went to college and learned
how to write screenplays and I was
horrible in English in high school and
became an English major in college I
started directing and learning how to
direct and learning really about the
film business which is probably the
number one thing that separates the
unemployed then and employed them was it
was the understanding of Hollywood and
the understanding of the business and
understanding strategy because so many
years I was just uh concerned with the
craft and all I thought about was how to
make the craft as good as possible I've
been acting since I was 7 years old so
that's always been a comfort zone people
would often ask me what do I enjoy doing
more acting or directing because I
started my career as a director and I
would say directing offers me the
opportunity to tell a story
acting is more of a therapeutic process
for me because as a kid I was always
like most kids curious about my identity
in search of my identity and when you
play a character the parameters of that
character and that identity are clear
there's something therapeutic about that
there's no guessing games when you fall
into character so if I'm not in
character
and I am usually in character unlike
other actors that can turn it off when
actually when that director says cut
I've never had that ability uh I'm
usually suddenly in character even after
the director says cut if you could talk
to your younger self knowing what you
know in those days when you thought
maybe it's not gonna happen what would
you tell yourself pretty cool I'd say um
I'd say play it cool and learn as much
as you can because everything you learn
you're gonna need you won't have enough
time to learn everything is in education
I see that the way you use social media
the way you reach out to your fans and
there is a very direct approach that you
utilize and some people don't do that
and some people can't do that but I
think it for you really embodies who you
are as a person and when you meet people
I'm embracing something like that is
that ever scary for you or is it just
Luke these are people that want to buy
your tickets and you'd love to talk back
to them um I think you have to be I
think there's something scary about
talking to a group of people anywhere if
you walk up on stage at comic-con you
yourself you could feel we all feel that
that little bit of anxiety before
speaking to a body of people so it's
it's no different on Facebook so if your
when you sit down there are times I
could sit down to to write a post and be
at that chair for two or three hours and
scrap the whole post and not put
anything off because you do want to be
thoughtful about what you're saying even
if what you're saying is something kind
of trite or seemingly insignificant as
ever
on the page nose there's always
something cryptic behind every damn
thing I say
and I I embraced it differently than I
get I think other people have or or
looked at it differently than other
people did early on when you know no one
had a million fans and it was brand-new
and and Obama had just gotten elected
and he used the the social media
platform to do that and it was still new
I looked at it as an opportunity to for
the first time in my life be able to
hear the audiences react thought out
reaction to my work or whatever film I
had done or characters that I might not
have done an exam for example Riddick
and so I feel like if I didn't have that
social media I don't think I would have
ever been pushed to make Riddick at the
same level it was the audience saying I
remember this one comment on a on a
Riddick post where and this was years
before we ever made the movie when it
was still kind of we were uncertain if
we'd ever have the rights to make the
movie and someone said hey then there
really needs to be another Riddick and I
you know we're really happy that you're
doing fast but we need another Riddick
and I'm sure that if all of us gave you
$10 you could surely get the money to
make it then rated-r the way you want to
there was something this before
Kickstarter and all that stuff right and
there was something so endearing about
that and that sentiment that I felt even
if I have to go make this movie for free
I've got to go make this movie it's
something that has resonated and
sometimes the audience the film going
audience
chose the studio and in this situation
that's exactly what happened I have a
studio initially the last decade didn't
think didn't know whether they were
going to be able to revisit this at the
high level and still maintain that rated
R and it might not have been made but it
was that audience that said it has to be
made and not Holly back in 2002 it was
you the MTV audience that first
acknowledged this Brotherhood between
Paul Walker myself by honoring us with
the best team on film so it's surreal to
be standing here twelve years later and
that you have been so generous to give
us this award again
I wish you could be here to see this but
I know he's here in spirit thank you for
honoring me and more importantly thank
you for honoring that angel my brother
Paul Walker
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because CJ Jones asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'm also curious to know which one of
Vin Diesel's top-10 rules had the
biggest impact on you and why what did
you learn from it what are you going to
apply to your life or your business
leave in the comments I'm going to join
in the discussion finally I want to give
a quick shout out to Sadat Virgie sedap
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book and taking that picture and
post it on Facebook it really means a
lot to me and I hope you enjoy and find
your one word so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much loved
I'll see you soon
so then I've heard you're really into
Dungeons and Dragons so I have two
questions
yes what character do you play and would
you be willing to join our group
[Music]
you know it's whenever anyone asked me
to join their campaign there's a good
old feeling I have where I feel like you
know I'm not alone in the world and it's
okay to be a dweeb um I I played a lot
of characters and I played the my most
famous character you might have read
about which was my witch hunter my half
draw witch hunter irony is I'm about to
next month to a movie called
the witch hunter kind of freaky I mean I
never thought in a million years when I
was rolling that 20-sided die 20
something you should go that Hollywood
would make a movie a little bit gentler
but that's another thing uh and yeah how
were you playing in on the East Coast
well we actually do it over video chat
you are doing video chat yeah so we've
got one guy down in North Carolina and
he will video in and there are you using
modules I'm um it's mostly second
edition rules but they have some
holdovers from the first edition so okay
thinking about it I mean we played with
I know cannon we played with everything
I mean that's where the witch hunter
witch hunter wasn't created by Gary
Gygax as you know it was an aftermarket
book so we were trying to incorporate
and create new games don't create it
it's a special time D&D was a special
time
yeah man we might have to get into that
yeah we might have to get into that I
can get into that man you know that Gary
Gygax as I told you I was gonna be in
dorky yeah up into breakout sessions
where I'll tell you later
Gary the movie opens up tonight at
midnight and in America so mmm how do
you explain the success all over the
world I mean in Australia in UK well I
have a Facebook there Daniel
almost 23 million people that doesn't
hurt but I think the audience really
appreciate appreciates the integrity
that goes into this phone so many action
films of this size are gratuitous and
don't take the time to work out story a
character dad heart and feeling and
emotion and romance I think that's what
elevates this movie I think this movie
you if you didn't see it
and you didn't see the last one you
could write it off as just an action
movie yeah but I think that the fact
that it's deeper than that and the fact
that it's multicultural yeah no action
movie has subtitles of people talking in
Spanish yeah but that's um or Portuguese
but that says something about what kind
of franchise this is
[Music]
got some serious balls now I've been
told no you're lucky I miss my shot I
think you hit your mark really what is
it with you well you got a death wish or
something that's what it takes I just
want to race I lose you car
let's do it
your funeral rather die remember